hola bienvenidos una vez más a esta
emisión de canadá en las américas café
el programa que le proponemos cada
semana desde el servicio en español de
radio canadá internacional
el viejo castor mensajero el reencuentro
con nuestro público a través de diversos
canales por eso aprovechamos a
saludarlos desde ya a quienes nos siguen
a través de facebook live que son cada
día o cada semana más y más quienes se
suman a esa vía pero también están
quienes prefieren nuestro canal de
youtube y por supuesto también saludamos
a quienes nos siguen desde hace años a
través de nuestro sitio en internet www
rcn t.co a todos ustedes muchas gracias
por estar aquí les recordamos como
siempre que esta emisión está disponible
a partir de primera hora de la tarde
horario de montreal del día viernes y
durante todo el fin de semana hasta el
lunes por la mañana hoy estamos aquí en
estudio
muchos varios en este caso integrantes
habituales del equipo
chapman
es tan hola a todos pablo gómez barrios
hola luis un gusto estar con ustedes
contento otro de nosotros siempre
contenta yo siempre contesto y leonardo
gimeno que te algunas tardes como días
de mentalidad
lo que sí exacto bueno contento a pesar
de que colombia ha perdido
y queda solo brasil representando a
américa latina
no quiere que gane brasil así que no no
no ahora pueden optar por otra cosa
también porque no bueno como verán
ustedes cada semana desde hace ya varios
varios días estamos inmersos las 24
horas del día en el fútbol no nos
podemos hacer el tema de la cabeza por
eso volveremos hacia el final del
programa
para narrarles mi nombre es luis labora
y además hoy estamos con invitados aquí
presentes en nuestro estudio se trata de
inés franch es franceschelli y lo digo
bien perfecto muy bien y des es
originaria de la provincia de córdoba en
la argentina pero se define como
paraguaya donde vive hace más de 30 años
34 años 34 años o sea una paraguaya
dicha y derecha completamente sí y
también está con nosotros darío solano
él viene de la república dominicana
gracias también por permitirnos estar
con ustedes al contrario gracias a
ustedes por estar aquí presentes
de tu providencia de república
dominicana encontraste a montreal muy
caluroso bastante es un poco más fuerte
bueno ustedes están aquí presentes para
un para varios eventos pero
principalmente para la denominada
conferencia para el fomento de la
conservación comunitaria de qué se trata
bien la coalición mundial por los
bosques es una red global de la que
participamos organizaciones de más de 60
países que trabajamos en distintas
líneas de acción de investigación y de
promoción y una de ellas probablemente
una de las más fuertes es la
conservación comunitaria
que es la conservación comunitaria es la
del productor es la defensa
de la naturaleza en los territorios de
la biodiversidad en los territorios con
la gente los seres humanos que habitamos
este planeta como tales desde hace
millones de años como sapiens desde hace
muchos miles y como como humanos
modernos
ya organizados en sociedades complejas y
manejando digamos los recursos naturales
por lo menos desde hace doce mil años
como agricultores y sésiles y
sedentarios en los últimos en las
últimas décadas se ha dado un proceso
muy acelerado de destrucción de los
hábitats a partir de este modelo de
producción extractiva que
a manos de empresas de grandes
corporaciones controlan todo el sistema
agroalimentario y además la producción y
la extracción de minerales y otras
formas productivas que atentan
directamente contra la la naturaleza las
condiciones de biodiversidad necesarias
para que sea posible la vida y además y
sobre todo atenta contra los derechos de
las comunidades de habitar estos
territorios cuando el modelo extractivo
a los grandes latifundios con
monocultivos la producción extensiva de
ganado avanzan sobre el territorio
lo primero que sucede es que expulsan
violentan y eliminan las posibilidades
de sobrevida de pueblos indígenas y
comunidades campesinas de todo el
planeta y en el caso específico del
paraguay que es el caso que supongo que
tú conoces mejor bueno paraguay
lamentablemente es un país que es una
víctima privilegiada de este modelo
nosotros tenemos para dar una referencia
5 millones y medio de hectáreas
cultivadas de las cuales el 96% se
destina a la producción de mercaderías
fundamentalmente soja maíz trans
soja transgénica y maíz transgénico y
apenas el 4 por ciento de esa superficie
está destinada a la producción de
alimentos
paraguay es dependiente completamente de
alimentos importados y produciendo
semejante volumen de proteína vegetal
tiene más de 2 millones de personas por
debajo de la línea de pobreza la
población campesina e indígena impactada
por esta realidad se desplaza a la
periferia de las ciudades a malvivir sin
fuentes de empleo porque además al ser
una economía primaria
paraguay no industrializar su producción
exporta prácticamente todo lo que
produce en estado natural
eso genera realmente una realidad social
y económica absolutamente insostenible
es un modelo de mucha violencia entonces
nosotros somos víctimas primeras de esta
realidad que estamos describiendo de
ontario solano tú vienes de república
dominicana y en el caso de tu país la
situación es similar es parecida y yo
pienso y es una realidad de américa
latina y el caribe están situadas en una
región que hasta ahora está definida
como la más desigual del mundo o sea es
una lógica donde
[Música]
y privatizan los beneficios se
privatizan los medios oficios y se
socializan las pérdidas y justamente la
lógica de desarrollo que se están
planteando es sobre la base de la
exclusión sean cada día más la riqueza
se concentran en pocas manos entonces la
república dominicana en este caso ha
dotado un modelo de desarrollo que
extiende
hacen aumentar la población y es un
modelo que plantea el turismo por un
lado por el otro lado la minería y que
lo que se ha visto injustamente en este
modelo y que la comunidad de locales o
sea los campesinos las comunidades que
tenga alrededor de los bosques que
tengan justamente en la tierra que son
apetecidas por estas empresas lo ven
como un obstáculo sin embargo nosotros
no planteamos que el mayor activo de
cualquier proyecto de desarrollo que la
gente y la gente vista desde el punto de
vista de un lenguaje de la
sostenibilidad
mucho más alternativo en la calidad de
vida sin embargo nuestro país se tiene
permanentemente aumento de riqueza
incluso de desarrollo sin embargo eso no
se expresa en las condiciones de vida de
nuestra gente al interior de nuestras
comunidades
y siguiendo un poco lo que están
diciendo acá y lo que dice lo que
hablaba inés es sobre la situación de
paraguay lo que significa esto todo el
planteo que estás haciendo inés es que
en realidad los únicos que pueden
cambiar esta situación de falta además
de hay una injusticia respecto a la
distribución de la riqueza en paraguay
hace que la gente pues cada vez sea más
pobres son las comunidades son los
únicos que pueden cambiar pues es decir
esa relación de fuerza es muy
desfavorable para mis esas comunidades y
para la población en general son los
únicos que pueden cambiar porque de
hecho en territorio donde los
ecosistemas se mantienen mejor en
mejores condiciones de equilibrio
biótico biológico
donde hay gente viviendo son las
comunidades las que conservan sus
bosques porque lo usan razonablemente
desde hace milenios en paraguay en
particular tenemos 17 pueblos indígenas
y más de 300.000 personas
autodenominadas denominadas digamos
comunidades campesinas
utilizan los bosques como fuente de
alimento de medicina como como fuente de
agua en el sentido de que donde la selva
paranaense la selva subtropical que
cubría con más de 20 millones de
hectáreas del paraguay
ha desaparecido y donde ha desaparecido
no hay más agua potable
y además
la condición de enclave digamos de
extracción que tiene buena parte del
cono sur hay que recordar en el 2004 la
empresa syngenta una compañía suiza que
es una de las grandes fabricantes y
comercializadoras de agrotóxicos publicó
una publicidad que decía tenía un mapa
que decía la república unidad de la soja
y pintaba el sur oeste de brasil la
mayor parte de paraguay buena parte de
argentina y una parte de bolivia
ese territorio ha sido destinado para la
producción de soja en la lógica de este
control
y corporativo del sistema
agroalimentario y ese territorio es el
que reporta mayores índices de
contaminación en elementos que son
fundamentales para la sobrevida de los
ecosistemas del conosur como el río
paraná o el río paraguay
y ni que decir
la contaminación de suelos y de aguas
subterráneas también hay que recordar
que este territorio es prácticamente
coincidente con el acuífero guaraní una
de la tercera reserva de agua dulce más
importante del mundo hay que recordar
que la producción o el cultivo de soja
mejor dicho produce una erosión un
desgaste ub de los suelos que inclusive
hace que esas tierras más tardes sean no
aptas para otro tipo de cultivos
la soja ya presenta problemas en el
conosur la multiplicación de malezas
resistentes la disminución de la
productividad como consecuencia de este
desgaste de suelo está dando paso a
nuevos rubros
en particular estamos viendo en el
paraguay en brasil y en argentina el
crecimiento y la expansión de los
monocultivos de árboles que los
organismos internacionales pretenden
llamar reforestación y las empresas
también llaman reforestación pero son
monocultivos con
el mismo impacto o peor impacto aunque
la soja árboles frutales
fundamentalmente eucalipto en brasil en
uruguay en argentina porque eucalipto
sobre todo a qué se debe porque es un
maderable de rápido crecimiento que han
logrado que tenga una alta productividad
de celulosa y eso iba a decir en brasil
uruguay argentina se son unos cultivos
para producción de papel en paraguay no
porque no tenemos empresa pastera
fábrica de fábrica de papel en paraguay
sea un fenómeno más cruel si cabe porque
están expandiendo la plantación de
eucalipto para producción de biomasa que
es la biomasa la leña es decir maderas
combustibles y en paraguay se usa esta
madera para convertirla en carbón para
secar los granos de soja en el complejo
sigue el chilero de las mega empresas
y lo peor es que fomentan los
monocultivos en fincas campesinas de 456
hectáreas el eucalipto seca el suelo
seca tanto agua en superficie como
subterránea y además tiene un efecto que
se dice alelo patico que es que no deja
crecer nada debajo del eucalipto y a su
alrededor entonces la llamada
reforestación finalmente pues es una
ilusión porque si se siembran sólo para
talar los después de hacer leña para
beneficio de la soja entonces como que
hay un círculo vicioso ahí bastante
nefasto y es una mentira es una mentira
sostenida para fomentar esta lógica de
la conservación o del ambientalismo sin
personas
es un ambientalismo una conservación
para la acumulación de riqueza
yo tenía otra preguntita sobre los datos
que vistes ahorita inés con respecto a
esta que en paraguay se consume sobre
todo productos importados quiere decir
que a nivel de la agricultura a nivel de
la producción local no hay suficiente
producción como para alimentar una parte
de la población hay una retracción de la
superficie cultivada hay una retracción
de la población campesina nosotros
tenemos un fenómeno migratorio realmente
extraordinario
docenas de miles de personas salen cada
año a emplearse en buenos aires o en
madrid o en otros lugares del mundo
fíjense ustedes del total de las
exportaciones del paraguay el 80 por
ciento es productos del agro negocio
fundamentalmente soja y vaca y largando
que existe esa política agro exportadora
en paraguay paraguay inició el fenómeno
de la sojización que le llamamos en el
año 96 con precisión ventas
argentina fue el primer país del mundo
después de eeuu en liberar en legalizar
la soja la primera la soja transgénica
rr la primera versión
esa soja se plantaba en argentina y
empezó a entrar de contrabando a
paraguay le llamaban la soja maradona
algunos dicen que porque venía es muy
simpático algunos dicen que era porque
venía de argentina pero los campesinos
decían que era que le llamaba a maradona
porque era bajita y necesitaba droga
para prosperar
en el veneno que le echaban
y en el 96 se da una acelerada
destrucción de la superficie de la
cobertura boscosa de la región oriental
que es bosque subtropical y empieza a
desplazar la producción ganadera
generando otro drama porque realmente es
una tragedia al chaco paraguayo ustedes
saben que el gran chaco sudamericano es
un ecosistema que es un complejo de
ecosistemas frágiles que hoy padece la
tasa de deforestación más alta del
planeta más acelerada del planeta porque
porque avanzó la soja
en la región oriental entonces la
ganadería se mudó al chaco generando
esta destrucción
darío tú perteneces a un colectivo de
nominados y si tengo bien el dato
plataforma de afrodescendientes es así
si los afrodescendientes en república
dominicana sufren de manera particular
estos fenómenos de los que estamos
hablando si éste la mayoría de las
comunidades donde son objetos de este
tipo de desarrollo justamente están
habitadas por comunidades
afrodescendientes y hay una
particularidad cuando hablamos de
comunidades afrodescendientes que la
república dominicana a pesar de que
mayoritariamente sus habitantes
afrodescendientes no hay una actitud de
parte del estado una voluntad política
de asumir la cotidianidad o sea la
cosmovisión de que es un país
directamente afrodescendiente cuando
escuchaba haines
un tanto manifestando todo lo que la
realidad desde poco que se viene dando
en paraguay y todo
y suramérica nosotros nos trasladamos a
la república americana en su modelo de
desarrollo en este momento se ha
centrado en tres pilares de la economía
y muchas veces nosotros nos decimos que
una un pilar de desarrollo que no nace
en el territorio y en este caso los
pilares de la economía dominicana se
basa en la remesa de los dominicanos que
devenga en el exterior en las zonas
francas que en muchos países de américa
latina le llaman
y que son de ensamble y en el turismo o
sea es un modelo de desarrollo que está
basado en lo externo ese modelo de
desarrollo que ha sido impuesto o sea
porque desde esa perspectiva es que no
has visto en el caribe tiene la
particularidad que no tiene ningún
impacto
en el interior de la comunidad en
términos de desarrollo en el caso de la
zona franca no hay una un intercambio de
tecnología pero además de eso se
instalan en condiciones muy favorables
incluso donde están libres de impuestos
o sea es una cosa extremadamente
excepcional frente a ese capital
internacional generan empleos pero
generan un empleo que más que se supone
que el nuevo grado no es productivo se
supone que el empleo tiene que generar
desarrollo en este caso el empleo que
genera en la zona franca no produce un
desarrollo primero son salarios de
pobreza
se enmarcan en jóvenes y sobre todo
mujeres y eso crea también algunos
crisis y en términos de lo que es la
corrección comunitaria entonces son
salarios muy de pobreza pero sobre todo
no le permiten hacer otro tipo de
actividades y en el caso del turismo
también muchas veces vemos en las
cuentas nacionales la cantidad de
millones de dólares que se registran
supuestamente en el banco central
pero ese tipo de no tiene ningún impacto
ese dinero se queda las transnacionales
que son las que mané los grandes
operadores de turismo y que se quedan en
el país y de repente cuando venía el
lunes para montreal
nos encontramos en punta cana con varios
aviones que venían para para mostrar y
recuerdo que le pregunté a un uno de los
canadienses que si había visitado a
república dominicana como una forma de
provocación no no visitó república
dominicana se quedó en un complejo
hotelero no tuvo contacto con con la
gente entonces de buenas a primeras ni
se esté destruyendo bosques o sea porque
hoy inclusive el sector hotelero desafía
y logra implementar leyes para utilizar
las zonas protegidas las áreas
protegidas o sea de qué forma el turismo
la zona franca de algún modo en el run
lo que es el equilibrio ambiental
y lo peor de todo que no tienen ningún
impacto en la generación de empleo de
calidad o decente como incluso último
tiempo habla la oit pero mucho menos un
impacto al interior de la comunidad de
todo lo contrario crean comunidades con
algunos niveles de comportamiento y
nosotros decimos que el caso de la
biodiversidad todo lo que era nuestra
diversidad biológica hay un elemento
fundamental que hay que tomar en cuenta
que también la diversidad cultural al
interior de las comunidades sea como la
cultura también recrea ese sentido de
pertenencia con el territorio existe una
industria agropecuaria realmente la
república dominicana no tiene una gran
industria agropecuaria no ha sido el eje
de buena primera nosotros hasta el 1900
hasta la última década los noventa
nuestra mayor producción de la caña de
azúcar pero esa cañada esa producción de
caña de azúcar era porque teníamos un
mercado este privilegiado en este caso
con eeuu inmediatamente de eeuu
sustituyó el azúcar productos de la caña
la industria azucarera
se fue a pique desapareció imagínense
que era el área productiva de mayor
empleo en el país y de buenas a primeras
amanecimos con todos los trabajadores en
la calle no hay más batalla están los
bateles es que muchas veces la
característica del batey es una zona
donde nos podríamos decir que hay vida y
al bate y está lo que el batey
tradicional poblado por migrantes
haitianos o sea con braseros haitianos
que vienen a la república dominicana y
al corte de la caña que justamente en
este momento se presenta una gran
dificultad porque la mayoría de los
descendientes de los jornaleros o sea de
los trabajadores que vinieron a buscar
que venían con un contrato de permanecen
en el país por seis meses y un año sin
embargo hoy tienen 40 años en el país y
en el 2013 en la constitución dominicana
es un problema de carácter humano o sea
y el desarrollo el modelo hay que verlo
de esa perspectiva justamente más de 200
mil personas hijos de migrantes
haitianos que según la constitución
dominicana eran
y canó de buena primera radio la
sentencia que le quita la nacionalidad y
le deja en una situación de apatridia es
que se aplicó esa ley sí sí se aplicó en
el ede del tribunal constitucional y es
una ley que entrelaza todos los
organismos del estado
claro está frame significa que república
dominicana está expulsando a los
haitianos que viven y que nacieron
incluso en república dominicana es la
gran paradoja la constitución dominicana
establecía que todas las personas que
nacían en territorio dominicano con
exclusión de los diplomáticos eran
dominicanos es república dominicana hay
una situación de antihaitianismo sea la
construcción de la nacionalidad tiene
una base de anti haitiana pero además de
eso también se ha desarrollado una
tendencia conservadora que plantea que
tanto
eeuu canadá y francia tratan de resolver
la problemática de pobreza de haití
unificando la isla entonces se crea una
situación del nacionalismo y lo que se
trata es de que estos haitianos a su
entender incluso manejando el argumento
que no tienen sentido porque si bien es
cierto que la constitución haitiana dice
que es haitiano
todo eso identidad no importa donde haya
nacido esos dominicanos hijos de
haitianos que nacieron república
dominicana no tienen ningún vínculo
ningún vínculo con haití y en términos
ambientales ya ustedes sabrán que la
capa rocosa de haití es sumamente pasa
por una situación muy crítica como para
ir cerrando el tema y retomando entonces
todos los argumentos que hemos planteado
aquí en la mesa esta conferencia para el
fomento de la conservación comunitaria
que se propone
es la segunda conferencia que la
coalición mundial por los bosques
realiza como decíamos al principio nos
encontramos personas de distintos países
desde los cinco continentes
y el objetivo fundamental es el
aprendizaje y el intercambio para
concertar estrategias comunes de
incidencia
a nivel regional y a nivel global
por decir que latinoamérica nos hemos
encontrado personas de distintos países
y uno de los elementos centrales de este
encuentro es el reporte de la urgencia
de reaccionar a una ola de
criminalización que no veíamos en
latinoamérica desde los 70 luchadores
defensores del ambiente y de los
derechos de los pueblos procesados
irregularmente y con impunidad presos
desaparecidos asesinados e inclusive
masacres de una crueldad que no como
digo no se ve ya hace décadas en
latinoamérica y eso ha generado en la
necesidad de de ponernos a pensar como
reaccionamos los pueblos
la situación política en latinoamérica
ustedes saben que es difícil estamos con
una después de una década de gobiernos
progresistas que estamos con una
y una regresión neoliberal muy fuerte
si el año pasado la asamblea de la omct
se realizó en buenos aires este año se
hace en diciembre la asamblea del g20 y
ambos espacios de incidencia global con
una agenda que nos llama la atención
básicamente el g20 está planteando tres
temas en la preparación de su asamblea
el primero de ellos es el futuro del
trabajo y estamos viendo en nuestros
países
flexibilización laboral y pérdida de
derechos con las leyes en brasil en
argentina con las reformas previsionales
la pérdida de la jubilación para la
gente
bueno pérdida de derechos de horario de
trabajo etcétera el segundo tema es
infraestructura para el desarrollo que
es toda esta arremetida con mucha
corrupción como lo ha demostrado el caso
de brees y demás de
y construir en latinoamérica al servicio
de la extracción con altísimo impacto
ambiental y social y el tercer eje que
está manejando los países ricos que es
el futuro de la alimentación eso implica
para nuestros países más monocultivo más
despojo de más subordinación y bueno la
conferencia se plantea esto como
armonizar que estamos debatiendo y como
como en toda la dinámica de la lucha de
los pueblos a lo largo de la historia
hay nuevas circunstancias y por lo tanto
nuevos desafíos nuevas visiones y eso es
lo que estamos construyendo
y sobre todo en esta conferencia nos
permite visualizar lo que la realidad de
nuestros respectivos países pero también
la posibilidad de cómo ir creando
sinergias a partir del aprendizaje de
las distintas experiencias que se vienen
dando en el mundo y sabes que estando en
latinoamérica y el caribe entender que
hay otros continentes que en igualdad de
condiciones pero sobre todo de verde la
posibilidad de crear solidaridad red con
el norte porque justamente los capitales
que se están que están generando este
tipo de conflicto en nuestros
respectivos países son capitales que
vienen de los países supuestamente
desarrollado entonces también entendemos
que tiene que haber un nivel de
sensibilidad frente en el interior de
estos países que conozcan cuáles son las
realidades o sea es importante
establecer comunicación solidaridad e
intercambio de experiencias con el
movimiento social de francia de canadá
de eeuu de alemania porque tenemos que
pensar en la casa
la casa comunes es la tierra y nuestros
bosques son fundamentales muy brevemente
quería aportar a esta idea que dice
darío
los sudamericanos cuando venimos a los
países del norte nos sorprende la
cantidad de embalaje yo veo cada mañana
que pasa la gente por la calle con una
caja de cartón donde hay un vaso de
plástico con una pajita que además está
envuelta en un papel una pajuela para
beber y pensaba esta mañana cada caja de
café que pasa un ciudadano canadiense es
el hambre de uno de nuestros chicos en
las comunidades entonces está este
intercambio de mirar que esta dinámica
económica y esta forma de consumir sobre
el planeta tiene un costo para el
planeta y para la para su gente también
acá al mismo al mismo tiempo aunque
pueda parecer paradójico hay una
conciencia muy amplia y que se está
extendiendo cada vez más del reciclaje
por ejemplo yo no sé cómo funciona esto
en américa latina pero acá se recicla
muchísimo se recupera el proyecto de ley
por ejemplo para dejar utilizar el
plástico
[Música]
las pajitas justamente para también
lugares donde están prohibidas así que
agradecemos entonces la presencia y
haines franceschelli a darío solano y
también esa cárcel que es la encargada
de relaciones con los medios de esta
conferencia para el fomento de la
conservación comunitaria muchas gracias
y les deseamos una final feliz de
estadía aquí en montreal y con menos
calor estuvieron sufriendo hasta ahora
muchísimas muchísimas gracias a ustedes
por permitirnos entrar en comunicación y
cerramos con ese eslogan conservar
nuestro bosque con y para nuestras
comunidades muchas gracias
seco
sigamos
y sexual
sexto
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bueno entonces vamos a dar lectura a
algunos mensajes de nuestros oyentes de
esos que nos envían semana a semana y
que no siempre tenemos tiempo de ver a
quien nuestro pide la palabra yo pido la
palabra porque tengo dos mensajes
importantes en el facebook uno es jim
rooms y que nos dice qué pasa con el
podcast me parece que no han emitido un
solo episodio desde el 6 de junio sigue
el podcast y nuestro servicio técnico me
dice que efectivamente están haciendo un
chequeo por las dudas de que haya habido
algún problema en la emisión del post
podcast de nuestro programa ni luis
balderas this estimados amigos de radio
canadá internacional quiero enviarles
desde el puerto de san antonio en chile
mis cordiales felicitaciones pues ya
hace 71 años que vuestra misión inició
sus transmisiones en español en julio de
1947 en que radio canadá comenzó a
hablarle al continente latinoamericana y
hasta hoy seguimos con mucho agrado sus
programas hoy en otras plataformas pero
notamos vuestro compromiso saludos e
felicidades por el tps aniversario del
español de radio internacional para
nosotros
congratulémonos entre nosotros mismos y
bueno con los mensajes
louis con respecto a una noticia
aumenta el número de venezolanos que
piden asilo en canadá
ismary ceballos dice hola gusto de
saludarlos y súper agradecida por su
atención a través de esta página
soy venezolana tengo 30 años con un
título de licenciada me imagino en
enfermería cinco años de experiencia
laboral pero debido a que hay un bueno
entonces yo creo que ella puede ser lo
que le gustaría es justamente venir a
vivir a canadá dice tengo muchas ganas
de emprender una mejor vida para mí mi
hija y mi esposo
el mensaje de maría ceballos yo tengo
acá un mensaje sobre historia del baile
y la rueda de casino salsa
escribe como ko más pain nos escribe
desde su correo electrónico y él dice
estos señores no pueden negar que son
cubanos dice mail me hizo reír este
mensaje dice cosa que caracteriza a los
ciudadanos cubanos era que esa pobreza
que vienen pasando desde los años 60
hasta la actualidad les empuja a querer
decir que hasta la pizza es cubana
porque no hizo no van a contar todas
esas desinformación a puerto rico
república dominicana nueva york donde
realmente crean y nace el género musical
fusión tropical creada por el dominicano
johnny pacheco y el puertorriqueño tito
puente en spanish harlem nueva york mis
queridos cubanos dice por favor al pan
pan y al vino vino dejemos de ser payaso
y usted porque se ríe
porque cuando uno escucha algo del
caribe de la salsa de buena primera me
dio risa por la alegría que genera el
tambor no por el mensaje
yo tengo aquí más de un mensaje referido
también a cuestiones de búsqueda laboral
como lo hemos dicho ya en reiteradas
ocasiones nosotros no podemos más que
brindarles la información respecto a
ciertas posibilidades laborales que se
abren en distintos puntos de canadá pero
la búsqueda laboral específicamente
corre por cuenta de cada uno de los
interesados en las distintas
posibilidades que se abren en distintos
campos y esa información está disponible
en el sitio de nuestra emisión a partir
de cada una de las entrevistas o
reportajes que realizamos como así
también en las distintas páginas de las
que disponen los distintos estamentos de
gobierno y de actividad económica y
empresarial aquí en canadá así que lo
bueno sería que cada uno
interesados se dirija a uno de esos
sitios para obtener una información
precisa sobre cada oferta laboral o
tienes algún otro mensaje si tengo un
mensaje sobre el tema neurólogo experto
en epilepsia ofrece consultas gratis en
español desde saskatchewan juan nos dice
buenas noches tengo 37 años soy maestro
mi caso es que en mi escuela uno de los
alumnos jugaba al trompo y se le zafó y
me pegó atrás en la cabeza no estaba a
una distancia de aproximadamente 10
metros viajo el trompo me sacaron en dos
ocasiones dos geografías y resultados
fueron negativos para fractura pero hoy
hace un año cuando presione el área en
la cabeza donde fue golpeado siento un
dolor leve pero dolor al fin y no
presenta dolor de cabeza solo dolor
cuando presione el área y bueno va a
parece que va a ser una consulta con
este experto en epilepsia desde
saskatchewan lo que lo que quiero
aclarar con eso porque están llegando
mensajes a nuestro sitio sobre esa
entrevista es que hay que dirigir si
está clarito allende en el reportaje hay
que dirigirse directamente al médico al
experto
porque él es el que está ofreciendo las
consultas gratis para todos aquellos que
tengan epilepsia y que no encuentren
respuestas a sus en este caso bueno
juanes dice que lo va a contactar la
cuenta y se trata su problema pero dice
que lo va a contactar muy bien siendo
que nos faltan menos de 10 minutos para
terminar la emisión y que nos quedan 355
mil temas todavía para abordar yo les
propongo el de los o sí
el de los o curioso el del oso perezoso
no del oso este a mí no se me dio tanta
pena es una cosa muy breve les voy a
contar por es un oso que mató a un tweet
en nunavut estaban en una especie de
campo de pesca y caza en y with it
ganadero como una cosa familiar y fue
una persona un papá con sus hijos y
salió el oso este del ártico que son
inmensos polar si el oso polar
el hombre esté al ver que estaba y no
tenía no estaba armado se interpuso
entre sus hijitos y el oso el oso lo
destrozó los hijitos pudieron salir
corriendo
bueno salvarse y había otro inuit ahí en
ese momento sacó su rifle y lo mató el
tema es que estos osos normalmente no
tendrían que estar en esos lugares pero
están llegando cada vez se acercan más y
más a dónde están estas comunidades en
busca de alimentos pues y además tal
entonces es una historia triste no bueno
porque yo quería acotar y perdona que te
interrumpa con respecto al oso porque yo
pensaba que estábamos hablando del mismo
oso y no está yo tengo otro soy este no
es un oso polar este es de estos osos
marrones que hay acá los que en los
bosques no más pequeños
en los bosques en los bosques de acá del
norte de quebec resulta que había una
patrulla de policía que andaba por ahí
que se estaba desplazando iba a un lugar
y salió este oso del bosque y se cruzó
en el camino entonces la patrulla pues
paró para no atropellar al oso
resulta de que el oso le llamó la
atención el carro y ellos empezaron a
tocar el [ __ ] del carro pero el oso no
no no se movía es más si se movió pero
para subirse entonces hay un videíto por
ahí que muestra esa idea y bueno son
historias que a lo mejor no suceden allá
en república dominicana millones
lo que pasa es que las historias que
suceden por ahí acción con los políticos
con los senadores y funcionarios
entonces muy rápidamente y sin más osos
del promedio vamos a presentarles a
nuestros a nuestro público los distintos
temas que hemos estado trabajando a lo
largo de esta semana y que ustedes le
sugieren en prioridad
quien quiere comenzar bueno yo me lanzo
es una historia curiosa porque son
muchachos que ve que es un muchacho
joven empresario que está teniendo mucho
éxito es resuelta de que este muchacho
estuvo viajando por indonesia y estaba
por allá y quería seguir viajando pero
desplazarse a un bajo costo no tener
información sobre vuelos baratos y todos
los demás y finalmente no encontró eso
que comenzó a hacer búsquedas en
internet y todo lo demás y no encontró
no encontró un sitio en el que le
pudiera decir bueno tenemos vuelos a
este precio entonces él decidió crear
una página web el es de desarrollador de
programas se trabaja en informática
entonces él se creó un sitio en el que
la idea principal es ir a buscar los
errores que cometen algunas compañías
aéreas
en los precios para explotarlo y hacer
aprovechar a la gente diciéndole bueno
si van ahora a este lugar en tal
compañía hay vuelos para tal lugar y tal
lugar más barato que de costumbre
entonces él cita un error que se produjo
y que el del cual él se aprovechó
también que fuera un viaje ida y vuelta
montreal parís por 195 dólares porque
alguien se equivocó en el precio
necesidad y desde 1950 entonces se
olvidó un cero por ahí igual entonces la
idea de este muchacho que se llama
alexis rúa es que se creó su sitio
internet que está teniendo mucho éxito y
que es muy frecuentado y que la idea es
rastrear los errores y los vuelos a bajo
costo para que la gente pueda pasear
ahora yo tengo el tema una entrevista
que hice con un trabajador temporal
guatemalteco es un caso que puedes estar
llevando a cabo ante la justicia acá en
montreal y que puede sentar precedentes
antecedentes son 15 trabajadores
temporales extranjeros que fueron
detenidos el año
un año y medio con una orden de
expulsión de canadá de quebec y de
canadá y entonces estos trabajadores
decidieron llevar el caso ante la corte
una corte federal es la segunda vez que
tienen una cita para presentar su caso
con es un caso complicado son 15
trabajadores que fueron son denunciaron
a sus empleadores pobre colocación por
estafa por trabajar 90 horas de
semanales y pagarles 60 en fin pero no
solamente eso sino que también estos
trabajadores en una agencia de empleo
aquí les había dicho que podía
conseguirles empleo en otro lugar en
otras granjas lo cual ellos aceptaron y
fueron pero resulta que eso está
prohibido por la ley cuando vos vienes
aquí de cualquier país de américa latina
y a trabajar en un lugar específico con
un desempleado es algo que no tienen
claro mucha gente exacto y ahí
cometieron el error y por eso se los
decidió expulsar pero entonces esa
expulsión está detenida el caso está
ante la corte federal de aquí de 15
quebec y están esperando la resolución
del caso
son 15 trabajadores que ya están están
trabajando en este momento a la espera
de que se resuelva el juicio pero lo
interesante es que pueden sentar
precedentes sobre este caso y ellos
esperan que sea favorable que puedan
quedarse y seguir trabajando y enviando
el dinero a sus familias en guatemala
entonces creo que pronto se va a conocer
el resultado de este juicio perfecto yo
no logro un poder de síntesis que vamos
a mirar bible la inteligencia artificial
en la justicia en varios lugares del
mundo está está en quebec se empiece a
investigar a 45 estibadores
internacionales hacen un proyecto para
ver si se puede en realidad si se pueden
acelerar los procesos en la justicia
mediante el uso de inteligencia
artificial perfecto aquí sintético que
precisó un muy bien el resto de los
datos pueden ir a fijarse el cei net
punto ce bueno y en mi caso les ofrezco
un breve reportaje que hice a partir de
la presentación de la orquesta sinfónica
de montreal en la localidad de brossa en
la ribera sur de montreal en el marco de
un ciclo que se llama la orquesta
sinfónica de montreal la vsm en los
parques que ya viene implementando la
orquesta desde hace mucho tiempo y que
implica sacar a la orquesta sinfónica de
sus
bellísima a la cama antesala inaugurada
hace muy pocos años creo que dos o tres
máximos y ir a los parques a buscar a la
gente oa ofrecer su música a la gente
que no tiene posibilidad o no se anima
simplemente uno toma la iniciativa de
xàtiva muchísima gente y de todas las
edades así que tienen ese pequeño
reportaje con un poco de música también
acompañando el mismo donde pueden ver
qué hace la orquesta sinfónica de
montreal cuando se sabe cuándo sale de
su sala a los barrios y no nos queda más
tiempo ni para más osos ni para fútbol y
para nada así que les agradecemos a
todos su presencia a través de la vía
que nos sigan facebook live youtube
rcd y net punto o sea los despedimos
hasta la semana próxima y les decíamos
que pasen un buen fin de semana con
menos calor que tuvimos hasta ahora chau
hasta la próxima
[Música]